on this episode we go Facebook wide hard
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
Carrie be
[Music]
yeah yeah super lives not just live hey
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 208 of the askgaryvee
show and this is a very very very
special episode of the askgaryvee show
as we continue an experience you know
what we had the golden era and I think
like this is last 2530 shows maybe 15
shows have been like the experimental
era right we've tried a lot of different
things you know we're trying to find our
cadence to the next thing and this is a
Facebook live episode so what we're
doing on this episode instead of the
call and we're using the Facebook live
technology there's all sorts of things
going on here Stefan's got a god I of
wire hanging out Brits actually live on
on it right now I just heard myself I'm
weirded out I have to collect my
composure but to get on this show right
now everybody watching live on Facebook
live you can actually ask your question
in the comments right - India India asks
boom the whole thing works
it's very 2016 I'm very excited about it
and also let's make sure that we share
bear it up everybody share right now if
you're watching share this up I would
love to get some new audiences into the
funnel of the askgaryvee show if you
care about your friends and family and
quaint saz and ex-boyfriends whatsoever
please share it up do you feel ready to
have some questions already I'm ready
I'm - you should we should really do
this like let's go out like so let's get
into the Facebook Facebook show yeah
ready okay yeah let's get into the
Facebook show by the way a really funny
thing a really funny thing is how many
people in Amsterdam asked me to do the
show it's become a whole mean when I
travel selfies and like hey would you
mind just doing the show with me and
then after like doing a dialogue you've
become a global icon in the
okay are you ready always okay first one
from Tony Tony what is the most
important lesson that you learned from
Mike what is the most important lesson
that I've learned from like that
I very much appreciate people who are
consistent and are willing to grind it
in the way that I like to roll and it's
very important for me to level up
everybody that surrounds me because
every minute counts
quality counts for Mike to not miss a
single day including the one time Mike
actually got drunk for the second time
in his life literally came in drunk dead
finished and just laid in the gym while
I worked out like late like like like a
baby like a like a like a 20 year old
like frat guy crushed from the night
before
like on the ground I think that drugged
me and the trout is housed by Frank
which is the funniest part so I that I
appreciate the you know that I'm a fan
of I'd love to say that I only talk
about what I believe in that when I see
it in somebody else it's extremely
valuable and reinforces the tried and
true two years the guy never missed a
single day like came through every time
do miss a single flight and really did a
tremendous job and so that consistency
does matter and I know I do it but
feeling it on the other hand was very
very rewarding and I'm gonna miss Mike a
lot over the next several weeks we'll be
around with your transition stuff but
like it's quite emotional for me yeah
Jordan Jordan not to beat you're not the
new Jordan that's Jordan is the name of
the new trainer yes he's in for three
years so we don't feel the transition
quite as quickly how would you scale a
wedding photography business with
basically no recurring dollars meaning
like like he just doesn't have a lot of
money yeah yeah he doesn't have a
business model that's recurring it's you
know I get a wedding a shoe did I get
money and how would you scale you know I
would first and foremost I think snapped
so if I'm a wedding photographer what
are the first moves I would do is very
similar to the advice that I gave to
designers immediately I would layer a
tier of snapchat filter capabilities I
believe every
wedding 35 and under in America in the
next 18 months is gonna have a snapchat
filter it's gonna be like a big thing
like Karen and Rick you know like that
thing so I would do modern marketing one
I would go triple in quadruple in all in
uploading all your photos five seven a
day get approval do your thing on
Instagram and learn all 15 hashtags that
matter on Instagram the five most
popular ones the five medium ones and
five longtail ones like hashtag Hamptons
wedding hashtag you know you know
Rockaway weddings like hashed your area
that you shoot in like there's always
that Hall you know that that like place
that everybody gets bad married that
using that name and weddings
so 15 hashtags against five to seven
photos every single day on Instagram I
think will lead to tremendous business
the other thing I would do is I would
try to guest blog on wedding sites about
Instagram and snapchat because again if
you're watching my show you're kind of
aware of these things right use modern
social creative as your linchpin to your
actual business if you think about being
a photographer for weddings as the
second everything and you think about
being great at snapchat and Instagram
around the wedding industry using it and
then commentating on it you will create
a much bigger awareness funnel and then
people like oh I want to use that girl
that guy they're good at snapchat
Instagram and wedding photos it's 2016
2017 so I would hustle like I would work
like what I just said to work like you
like that one nd it's real it's work
three more four more hours a day to do
what I just told you and amazing things
happen you know many people like Oh
miraculous ly I made $500 this weekend
on eBay because instead of drinking
beers on my porch and watching you know
thunder the Warriors I went through my
garage or white garage saling and I sold
stuff Stefan's smile because he watched
all
so here's five dollars less fish market
but he has the memories and shape ISM
rankings from ash ash what is the best
advice you can give to someone who wants
to start a small business but they're
still working full time to do it after
your hour so it's called crushing I
wrote in no 8 it came out no 9 7:00 p.m.
to 2:00 in the morning this is all the
same things are you guys willing to put
in the work and pay guys are you willing
to pay the price for what you want I
want to have a business so I can make
lots of money and go on vacation and
have lots of things you want a 1% life
but you're not willing to put in a 1%
work ethic work your job come on and do
I have to go through it again like to
have to have to make fun of Game of
Thrones and the Golden State Warriors
one more time I'm more than happy to
you've got to give up all the leisure
stuff and you've got to work from 7:00
to 2:00 in the morning start a business
sell [ __ ] on eBay I put that out there
everybody can do that
become the wedding photographer of
America like I became the wine guy
not everybody can do that but you've got
to make the mental switch in the same
way that two years ago I said I'm gonna
make the mint there was no tactic to get
into better shape like this might get in
here but get in here the time was
unbelievable I'm just talking about like
my health switch
ironically you start around the time
that I was starting to like smoke around
it yes you're you're an unbelievably
athletic kind of dude you agree with me
that it is a mental switch or not a
tactic there's no like you're gonna do
this it's it's binary either you're
mentally in the place of like I take
that seriously or you're not yeah cuz
life does whatever it's gonna do it you
just kind of decide what you're gonna do
around it so and that happens with the
with exercise - I think so yeah just go
with it you don't 1 or 0 what is zero
thank you
so do you remember two years ago we were
at the Boehner camp and he climbed the
wall in one second do you know about
this they like this wall thing and
everybody's like really yeah
one second yeah he's a machine anyway
like what's mine what's the person's ash
ash ash what's my recommendation is
unless you've been in my cycle for the
last 30 or 60 days and I'm new to you
I'm gonna get really pissed off at you
like the work and by the way you may not
be good enough to make 10 million
dollars a year with the work but you
might make four thousand dollars but
it's still gonna be the work like I
can't instill more talent into you you
can do a very good job of trying to find
white spaces and figure out what you're
good at but once you put in the work
that the talent the white space is
that's a coin flip that's a lot of DNA
that's a lot of luck that's a lot of
skill there's a lot of things there but
the work is always part of the equation
and that's the part none of you want to
do let's just can we just finally have
this conversation together you just
don't want to do it you just don't you
really don't you say you do but you
don't
you'd rather lay in bed and sleep in for
15 hours you'd rather play video games
you'd rather play [ __ ] games on your
phone you'd rather watch TV you'd rather
watch this show you'd rather go play
beer pong you'd rather do something else
than work it's hard it's hard it's hard
which is why I push people to doing work
around their passions because that makes
it a little bit easier if I had to do
this around bricklaying
I'd suck and you know what from Rob Rob
you're a huge sports fan
yes which athlete do you relate to the
most or compare yourself to as in you're
the blank of digital marketing I don't
really think that way but I will say
that you know watching the Kobe
documentary on Showtime definitely I was
like boy can I really relate
like I'm so scary and like I don't
really should like it's unbelievable
like I wonder what dailyvee episode is
gonna really show how competitive I
really am
there hasn't there's no I'm not
competitive with this audience I love
this audience I'm trying to give you
guys advice I don't even want you to
watch me anymore like think about that I
love this audience I'm not competitive
with people that have anointed me and
gifted me with their time and their
effort and their and their attention I
have love for them you should see the
polar opposite of my love because it's
dark like it's unbelievable how much I
hate my competition with like this rule
hate but then like in real life I don't
like I want to kill them in business I
want them to go out of business but then
I want to help them get back on their
feet but don't [ __ ] compete with me
no it wasn't and I was like I'm telling
you right now that's not even like we're
like do you know how weird I am do you
know that me taking the fight to we
talked about this once or twice like
when do you know adness brushing agnus
okay I need yours because you always
like doesn't lag yeah
I need you just for a second hey stop
doing this right because I'm talking
about like this dark place I go into
when I compete right and so there's that
one moment I don't know if you remember
but I do where you had a break away and
I came from behind you and then you just
shove these in floor like no mercy more
powerful to hear from you that was
probably inappropriate right now that's
very competition have it all the time
winner
that's a winner's mentality um this is
where me yesterday cuz you're a warrior
so look very I'm sure to awesome I think
we can all bring the end this is not a
six foot five brooding man she was on a
breakaway there was nothing really there
that they step on that thing
those a while ago yeah yeah when I just
like yeah yeah inappropriate 1989 and
then 92 MBA Knicks Pistons madness the
girl yeah yeah that was inappropriate
but when it's a competition
I do not care this by the way it
actually works for me as a positive for
vaynermedia I always laugh about
minority female things I think this is
competition whoever I think and like
like I don't care what even Patriot fans
are allowed at Vader right so like I'm
uh I'm very dark when it comes to
competition so the Kobe stuff of like
you know even and I hate Michael Jordan
with my heart and soul but even his like
speech where he's just like it's all
about competition it's it's the game I
love the game I don't like anybody who
wants to beat me and I and I really want
to beat their face in with a brick I
mean it if you agree like invest like
I'm I'm mad right like I come like when
we play I'm mad and that's basketball
you haven't seen me play Scattergories
maybe playing trivia right Christmas
party wait that was first when we met
right yeah and that was like I was weird
competitive you and Mike were super
competitive right like I was very upset
yeah even if you weren't necessarily
like contributor you were very upset
that's right
I didn't have any answers to these
questions I was mad at them for not
knowing like that's like you know I was
like you should know something do my do
plenty of things around here we have
this trivia party because I movie I
don't watch movies you [ __ ] babies
time to watch movies I don't know movies
I don't watch them Carson Carson Carson
how would you advertise a little house
in the southern Spain near the ocean I
rent it I have a website advertisement
agency and I do Airbnb but I still need
more customers thanks and greets
snapchat Instagram Facebook this is so
Instagram hashtag strategy is
unbelievable why don't you give away the
house to 50 influencers on Instagram
that have a million followers DM them
and say I this beautiful house here I
would like you to come out why don't you
reach out to you know Turkish air or
Delta or Virgin America or some like
that and say I've got this house I want
a surprise and delight five influencers
on Instagram and have them come and stay
and then what you say is all you have
news have five photos tagged this use
this hashtag if you ask every airline in
the world 99.9 percent of them will say
no and one will say yes because they
just talked about influencer marketing
the day before now you can go an
Instagram message somebody who's got two
million fans and there's a pretty girl
or boy and say you should come and stay
in my house in this beautiful place I
will have your flight taken care of you
can stay in my place in return I want
ten social media pieces of content tag
this game over winner over then hashtag
culture figure out which hashtags are
being used and put out way more content
more content content
content content is the cost of entry for
relevance in our society thank you let
me talk to my joke tell sang tell sang
gone crazy Newsday how you going to talk
much about mobile first websites advice
for doing it well and how do you
structure them for success I mean that's
ui/ux talk that's a bee testing that's
first recognizing that mobile first
websites are the cost of entry in 2016
like if you're not mobile first you're
gonna lose so when you design you think
mobile then you think desktop number two
you test your add to cart button you
test your sign up for my email service
you test different colors different
positionings a be testing you know I
don't talk about it because there's a
ton of people that are far more
knowledgeable about the UI and UX of
mobile optimization for websites and I
bet you they have tons of blogs and
videos out there and there's a site
called Google and go search stuff and
I'm sure you'll find four to seven
personalities the way I understand
consumer behavior and marketing in a
social digital mobile landscape I'm sure
there's plenty of gals and guys that
know how to do it anyone like a picture
in your that's great let me see yours
that's a great shirt you're wearing
today oh yeah that was the holiday party
day do you know what was the recall
where you were there from when we did
the camp at Lyndsey's did you see me
play volleyball No yeah Lauren Brander
was scared sorry Lauren all right from
Shan Shan what returns have you seen
with influence or marketing is it just
for massive brands like Samsung are
gonna start up turn revenue from
influencer marketing a startup can earn
revenue from influencer marketing
influencer marketing is reaching
awareness and it works it's a boring
question everything that works works for
everybody it's just not it's just
possible that you haven't figured out
your version of making it work like like
television Super Bowl is more expensive
than late-night remnant inventory but
you can get it like you know everything
we're influencer marketing works so
underpriced alright search hashtags are
on your business find people that are
influencers you know if you're in a
niche business somebody who has a
thousand followers may be the biggest
influencer because you're not you know
we can weight loss or in beer but you're
in SAS business API stuff but some nerd
it's got a thousand people like the nerd
probably cost nothing and by him or her
out by Mandy Jake said what are the best
ways to vanquish my enemies which I also
like you know but I actually have a
great answer this question great cuz
this is really what I do which is ironic
based on what we just talked about with
competition that to me being such an
insane contradiction there's gonna blow
your mind by not giving them the time of
day it is insane how much I don't
understand about my competitors I don't
even know their names that's how much
disrespect I have for them I'm being
dead serious
I never spent a minute I knew what the
other wine stores were doing I know the
names of the other agencies that are in
our space I don't have a damn
clue there hasn't been a minute on my
calendar in the last 36 months that was
based on getting recon or intrigue on
what any competitor of mine is doing
because the very honest truth is it
doesn't matter what they're doing
because I'm gonna get mine and if
they're good enough they'll get theirs
second second rate I'm gonna get mine so
how do you banish them by establishing
that they're vanished from the get what
do you want but very I'm gonna salt you
Bhima I'm getting very competitive you
want to ask the poll you want it you
want polls you want to poll you want to
throw it up there so I'm gonna say
something come up with a poll you're
gonna create an out yes it needs to be
half that answers in the comments to be
hashtag they have to answer in comments
hash tag whatever to my question yes
okay who do you like more hashtag India
or hashtag d-roc results will like show
up live it's really cool it's amazing
okay wait rock it out yep in the
comments hashtag India or hashtag d-roc
and don't just come in here and do rocks
not don't like pick India they could be
like do you rock more more number three
hashtag share their whole sure birds
gonna win service okay good I knew I
think we need to produce share bear
plush toys that's like a gay Andrew he's
his birthday no it's his birthday is
gonna happen let's do it the travel of
the show I like this I like this luck do
they like it work what are they saying
in the comments what's happening the
people I know like Laura birds are cool
because the questions are probably not
that the bomb right but like what's the
feedback do your eyes game a lot wealthy
Brock has dailyvee like Adia as
dailyvees become a little bit more like
what you know if we ask this question
you know just four months ago India
would have crushed him but now it's Iraq
but soon can be Stefan because everybody
gives d-roc love and then I jump in him
like that Stefan great at it I right
nope are you you're editing right now 40
right yeah how's it coming I haven't
started yeah I just got the stuff how
long until the older generation get
snapchat they said they would never go
on Facebook and we saw how that turned
out haha from Michael haha Michael soon
give me another one another one try and
do a lightning round India getting over
the fear of starting due to potential
theaters and also what's your tip on
handling ears love your haters at number
two getting over to fear is something
you got to wrap your head around like
like it's just the cost of entry like
you will never do anything great if
you're scared I've worked in the
building supply district for ten years
and that time I've made many business
connections and I know many small
business owners in my area I know
something I have $500 a computer
internet car and a smart phone what's
the best way to start a referral and
leave generating business to get more
than 500 bucks go to ebay and let me get
5,000 bucks and then start hustle to
your if you have 500 bucks anymore I
mean you don't need more but like I'm
very very very big on on understanding
that's something like leave referral
you're gonna have to run ads you're
gonna have to create landing pages like
that's that's not what you do with 500
bucks it's like you put you you build up
5,000 bucks and I think there's 3500
dollars worth of junk in there in your
basement and your garage or your
auntie's garage get that [ __ ] flip it
make that cash India oh sure man oh
where does it put him on my shoulder
guys I love you thank you so much for
supporting on my content has been
amazing 60 60 days the shorts on on
Facebook two of two of them getting 20
million organic region
the you know multiple million reach
thank you so much keep sharing the
content it means the world to me it's
the it's the greatest gift that you give
me episode two a success I think you
know for a first time to do this I think
we've got something here we'll come back
to this Thank You India yeah question of
the day which you can leave in these
comments to as this wraps up question of
the day the whole live experience
periscope Facebook live which it really
takes on it what do you like what do you
don't like
are you watching anything give me your
two sentence thesis on the live
revolution that is happening right now
on the web you can ask me questions I'll
keep answering them
what's up guys hope you enjoyed the show
please do I get to link it up anywhere
is it like in here or is it down below
is it in print or is it in my video it's
here down to my left
like right here there's a button for
them to subscribe to my youtube video
yeah it's a little buggy thing that's
right guys click this that's right use
that